why so many people are developing monkey
pox around europe all at the same time
is perplexing scientists at its worst
the disease can look alarming but the
viral strain behind the current outbreak
can cause just a milder rash that
blisters over and scabs rather like
chickenpox the puzzle is why a disease
endemic to parts of africa and
transmitted largely by animals is
suddenly spreading so widely between
people most likely through direct skin
to skin contact
they're viruses that are new in human
populations whether or not they've been
there for several years and all of a
sudden got into an amplifying population
is not clear it may have been that they
were transmitting in a slow chain of
transmission
among family members or somebody related
and all of a sudden it got into a
population which was more promiscuous
had more physical contact and therefore
it amplified in its transmission the
health secretary tweeted that he has
updated g7 health ministers underlining
how seriously this is being taken the
outbreak is very different to covet
numbers are small but with another
animal virus spreading in humans this is
no time for complacency
the first case was isolated at a
specialist infectious diseases unit at
guy's and thomas's hospital in london on
may the 7th they had recently returned
from nigeria and it looked like a rare
travel related case but since then there
have been many more and there's no
obvious connection between them
most of the known cases are in london
with some confirmed elsewhere in the uk
but there are also parallel outbreaks in
spain and portugal and cases reported in
france italy germany sweden belgium the
us canada and australia and this is a
disease that typically doesn't spread
well between people
due to the reports of infections
worldwide and the quick information also
from the robert koch institute doctors
and patients in germany were isolated
based on the knowledge available so far
we assume that the virus is not easily
transmissible and that this outbreak can
be contained
this can succeed if we act very quickly
the uk government has ordered more doses
of smallpox vaccine which hasn't been
routinely used in the uk since 1971
it is also 85 effective against monkey
pox and it can be given after exposure
to the virus to stop symptoms that along
with public awareness and contact
tracing will be key to bringing the
outbreak under control
thomas more sky news